and coronary artery bypass graft surgery
or CABG is performed to
improve circulation to the
heart muscle in people with severe
coronary artery disease.
bypasses the
blockage of a coronary artery that
carries oxygenated blood to the
heart muscle it is possible to
bridge one or more coronary arteries
in a single operation before surgery
an IV tube will be placed and
possibly given
medication to help you relax
CABG procedures
are performed under
general anesthesia so you will be sleeping during the
operation a breathing tube will be
inserted through your mouth and down your
throat to aid breathing
during surgery a catheter will be
placed in your bladder good for urine
for surgery  revascularization
usually takes from  3 to 6 hours in a
conventional surgery the surgeon
first makes an incision in the skin over
the breast bone or external the surgeon
cuts to the external and moves the rib
cage to reach the heart
throughout the process the
circulatory system will be connected to a pump
cardiopulmonary bypass machine or cardiopulmonary bypass
machine
during surgery this machine
temporarily performs the functions of the heart and
lungs allowing your heart
to stop so the surgeon can suture the
graft in place for the grafts
usually one of these two
blood vessels internal thoracic artery is used  of the
thorax or the saphenous vein of the leg to
fill the entire internal thoracic artery the
surgeon leave the upper extremity
connected to the subclavian artery and from
the general lower extremity of the
chest wall to the coronary artery one and the
obstruction then the surgeon
sews the graft in place to
saphenous vein grafts the surgeon
sew to one end to  the garden
and other end narrowed artery
just beyond the obstruction with grafts
firmly in place the surgeon uses
electrical signals to restore the
heartbeat and temporarily
puts a pacemaker in the heart
once the heart resumes normal rhythm
the machine  cardiopulmonary bypass is
turned off the surgeon will attach the external
trust special for surgery and suture
the skin incision to close a
drainage tube will be placed temporarily
through the skin below the incision
other types of CABG procedures have
been
recently developed to
bypass surgery without  pump and
minimally invasive bypass surgery pumpless
coronary bypass is also
called beating heart bypass
because the heart is not stopped and
the cardiopulmonary machine is not used
instead I used a
mechanical device to stabilize the part of the
heart where  it's being real  Once the
graft is performed surgeons perform
minimally invasive revascularization procedures using
specifically designed instruments
that are inserted through small
incisions or ports in the chest these
procedures sometimes require the use of
a cardiopulmonary machine after
surgery you will be taken to the
intensive care unit  the activity of your
heart will be carefully monitored
if necessary
the pacemaker electrodes will be used temporarily
to control your heart rate the
chest drain will remain in place
to drain excess blood EA from
the chest cavity as you
breathe the tube on your own
breathing tube will be removed and replaced the
oxygen mask the bladder tube will
remain in place as
you recover Over the next
three to four days gradually
all devices will be removed